today we are going to murder some people
with fire
*epic music*
*facecam*
*weird sounds*
Welcome to Yandere Simulator!
My name is PewDiePie!
Listen, if someone hits on your... girl.
Or your - or your boy.
Or your...
dog? (confused pewds)
You gotta pay them back. You gotta pay it forward.
Just fuck that one movie.
So we're gunna murder them.
*dramatic killer music ah so scared plez cuddle me edgar*
But first! (Lemme take a selfie)
There's a couple things you need to do!
Number 1.
Get a bucket. (To... suffocate them?)
*Weird butt liking noises*
Oh shit.
*more weird butt liking noises and the chicken chasing song playing wtf is this*
Bucket.
BUCKET!
*scary gothic music :O*
step 2:fill da BUCKET
step 3:splash a BITCH
*some guy starts talking stupid shit,pewds loves dat ass*
oh my fucking gawd
let's-let's stay on target
w-we need..bucket*get rekt*
*splashing sound*
fuck..tch ahahah
nice hat, BITCH
*kisses*
*pro music,dat beat tho*
can i have ma bucket back...?thanks guys
there she is!*arghhhh*
there she is
okay okay alright
you ready for this??
pour*just one word?*
*music of relief*
*kyaaaaa!*
*mlg prooo!*
let's check around,where is she?
where the fock is she?!
hey,come back here
hey can i have my water back please
come on babe
come on
oh
o-Oh
*pervy pewds*
nevermind you can keep the water
a'right let's get some good f-shots
oh my loard
holy shit
bikini...split
oh my loard
holy-oly
holy howarle hawoly
alright we played enough with water
now let's get into the real bissuness
*hell music starts to play*gasoline bissuness
BUT!!..to do this we need 5.THINGS.
THAT'S RIGHT you guessed it right
5.panty shots we need 5 panty shots
kyu the panty shot m-m...montage
*awesome music starts to play*
eugheue
*panty shots taken*
so now
fuckin work
i just got my bucket of-a..piss?!?!?!?
nothing wierd or suspicous about it
OH there she is!
oh gawd she's close to senpai
that bitch
she's gonna get what she deserves
blirch!!!!
*protect your ears!!!!*
you can dry yourself with this!!
oh god don't you fucking run away from me
come on x4
hey x4 where are you going?!?
oh gawd dammit we gotta hurry up!!
she's gonna wash herself!!
*throws a match,but misses*fuck
*throws a match again,buuut misses*fuck
we do not have much time
*matches again...*
we don't have much time goddammit
yaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
yuuuuuuuuuhhhhhhhhhh
oh
o-o-o-oh *close your ears!!!!*
cool girls don't look at burning up their friends
they just wa-oh my gad
that should teach not to fuck with SENPAI
hi guys
just uh-just brought my pickleoudo
guys it's NORMAL what-what? it's my carpet
aw shit
my god get outta here you fucking pussy
get outta here
there's one more way you can fu-actuallly there's many,but we are gonna do one more way,to fuck with this girl
first off you gotta level up your strenght,which you can do with a click of a butt*laughs*
you take the dumbells,you place the dumbells,you carry those...
holy shit i'm fuckin strong man
you could walk up to the cieling,but...
fock it
and now we play the waiting game
there she is
okay here we go,drop
*song of relief*
OH!
HUEHAHAHAH
OH MY GOD
eyyyy,eyyyyy